Наввипередки до поліграфа народні депутати України потягнулись після публічних обвинувачень
в отриманні хабаря членами парламентського Комітету
з питань фінансів, податкової та митної політики.
За допомогою так званого "детектора брехні" вони хочуть довести свою невинуватість.
Українські політики вже не вперше звертаються до поліграфа, коли хочуть відбілити репутацію.
Це вже традиційний популярний піар-хід, до якого вдавалися і депутати, і держслужбовці.
Адже сама лише готовність пройти такий тест
багатьма сприймається як доказ щирості та чесності.
Поліграф - це багатоканальна контрольно-вимірювальна система,
яка документує динаміку зміни фізіологічних показників організму людини.
Прилад вимірює динаміку дихання, серцевий ритм, артеріальний тиск.
Для цього до тіла людини прикріплюють спецремені на грудях,
металеві датчики на пальцях та напульсний тонометр на зап'ясті.
Головне, що варто знати - поліграф лише фіксує фізіологічні показники людини.
А от висновок на основі цих реакцій щодо того, бреше певна особа чи ні,
робить поліграфолог, тобто людина з відповідною кваліфікацією.
Фізіологічні параметри, заміряні поліграфом, можна трактувати по-різному.
Людина, яка боїться незаслужених звинувачень, може пітніти та хвилюватися так само сильно,
як і людина, яка боїться викриття, вказують фахівці.
Не виключені й спроби маніпуляції з боку респондента
за допомогою заспокійливих медикаментів.
Професійний спеціаліст мав би це помітити й перенести тестування.
Значною мірою все залежить від неупередженості і обізнаності самого поліграфолога.
Адже, якщо, наприклад, йдеться про тест щодо причетності до політичної корупції,
поліграфолог мусить мати досвід з такими справами.
Окрім того, йому потрібен час, щоб вникнути у суть справи.
Ринок послуг поліграфологів в Україні доволі великий:
лише у Всеукраїнській асоціації поліграфологів налічується понад 300 спеціалістів.
Відповідно, оскільки йдеться про власну ініціативу,
кожен політик може піти до будь-якої контори на свій вибір.
Так, перші депутати від "Слуги народу" звернулись до приватних поліграфологів,
не очікуючи розслідування справи державними правоохоронними органами.
Тож не виключено, що у ролі клієнтів вони мали можливість отримати зручні для себе питання,
які зазвичай обговорюються під час попередньої співбесіди,
а також результати тесту, вважають оглядачі.
Натомість і Служба безпеки України, і Державне бюро розслідувань
мають своїх поліграфологів з досвідом розкритих кримінальних злочинів.
Окрім того, обидва депутати - Олександр Дубінський і Олександр Качура -
проходили поліграф на камеру, що фахівці взагалі вважають неприйнятним,
адже це не лише перетворює тест на шоу, а й впливає на результати.
На камеру людина може поводити себе зовсім інакше,
особливо якщо це публічна особа, яка звикла виступати у певній ролі.
Нині в Україні дослідження на поліграфі
досить широко застосовуються у кримінальному провадженні.
Втім, результати тестів не є вирішальним доказом в українських судах.
Пройти тест на поліграфі - популярний серед українських політиків
засіб довести свою непричетність до злочину.
Утім, на сто відсотків довіряти результатам "детектора брехні" не можливо.
На них може впливати надто багато факторів -
від вибору поліграфолога і його професійності та неупередженості
до умов проведення тесту й налаштувань апаратури.
Зрештою, ідеться лише про інтерпретацію фізіологічних показників людини
у певний відрізок часу.